[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
food
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello
ladies and gentlemen necks and heisters
evil ais and children of the prime
welcome to the one year anniversary show
of prime mata this is lucy our prime
influencer and streaming manager and
this is steve our prime's community
manager thank you we are so excited to
be here with you today as we look ahead
at some of the games that we've got
coming up in the future as well as
reminiscing about some of those titles
we've launched over the last year
but first let's start with a quick
sizzle reel to look back at all the
games that we've launched so far and
show you exactly what primeter is all
about
come on it is a beautiful day
on citadel
station to del station their number
like a countdown timer of the universe
[Music]
nobody
i know what you're looking for is
revenge
to take humanity forward
their blood is on your hands
a pathetic creature of meat and bone
hello father
[Music]
fine matter
well that was quite something yes it was
and i hope you are all as hyped as we
are to dive into some of these awesome
games in a little more detail
don't worry there's no interviews
anyway aren't you supposed to be getting
changed oh crap
okay is she she ready yeah okay
action
and now i welcome you to join me as we
head into the prismic spiritual retreat
located on a sunny and remote island in
the pacific northwest to cleanse our
spirits and allow ourselves to transform
we will overcome our personal demons
challenge ourselves in ways we have
never known before
our bodies and our minds will become one
are you ready to join a new age
peggy 16.
welcome
i'm sure you have many questions
but isn't that how our spiritual journey
begins
honestly i'm
i'm not a very spiritual person
we are opening ourselves up to the
infinite
there used to be another group here in
the 70s
this can't be real
it's the gloom lying to you don't listen
to it
hello
the chant is a single-player
third-person horror action adventure
game set on a remote spiritual island
retreat to survive you must craft fight
and escape the psychedelic horrors set
loose when a ritual goes wrong and
awakens a dimension of cosmic terror
get ready to experience a spiritual
nightmare when it launches in fall 22.
and now we travel from this idyllic
island retreat to the dark city
underworld of scumland get ready to grab
your cerberus handguns and experience
the bullets beauty and badass of good
grave gore
it's the end of the line for you crave
[Music]
phew that's right the ultimate
gunslinger of resurrection grave is back
and ready to slay currently in
development by korean studio iggy mob
and set for release in fall 22 gungrave
gore is a bloody ballad of bullets
taking you on a journey to a dark
futuristic version of southeast asia in
a bid to eradicate dangerous alien drug
seed from the world
it's an epic story of revenge love
loyalty and a coven load of bullets
commander let's head to review prime
dolman released a little under a month
ago from the brazilian indie developers
massive work studio so allow me to show
you a quick trailer and welcome you to
erase your timeline
peggy 16.
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course throughout next week we
will be playing dolmen live on this
twitch channel and we'll be dying a lot
so make sure you follow our socials and
join our discord to know when we'll be
going live next
now who's ready to enter citadel station
once again
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
from the stars i i i want to watch as
you sculpt i watch as you scurry around
this planet like parasites living lives
devoid of meaning
i
have
plans for each and every one one and one
every one of you
let us celebrate
my vision showdown it's not your
celebration it's one
[Music]
i am a god
i have created new forms of life
and your impudence will not go
unpunished
uh thanks for dropping by uh showdown as
i said we will be headed back to citadel
station to warshi i mean fight shoden as
she tries to destroy mankind once again
in system shock a full remake of the
classic 1994 game the game has been
remade from the ground up with the
original members from the original team
including the original voice actress of
showden terry brocius to bring this
classic title to both existing fans and
new ones alike
in system shock you are a hacker that
has been caught by try optimum or
hacking their database having been taken
to citadel station you are forced to
remove shogun's ethical restraints a bad
idea
after six months in a healing coma you
awaken to the twisted aftermath of a
terrible disaster once a prime research
facility citadel station is now filled
with mindless mutants robots and deadly
cyborgs that are all programmed to serve
shodhan
when we revealed our latest trailer
during the pc gamer show where inspector
a renowned game developer and one of the
original team members of system shock
said he's amazed with the remake so we
have all of the pieces of great game in
place with eye-popping visuals iconic
villains
[Music]
and a legendary developer it is gaming
history in the remaking so let's take a
look
peggy 18.
humans
interfacing with computers
for their own entertainment
the very notion disgusts me
look upon my works foul creatures and
weep at its magnificence
it is a beautiful day
on citadel station
humanity is on the verge of a new era
i showdan and its new god
look at you hacker
a pathetic creature of meat and bone how
can you challenge a perfect
immortal machine
you are an insect you are
nothing
i create
i iterate
i fuse flushing steel
their blood is on your hands
you will suffer for your transgressions
transgressions these are my other
avenging angels
and they will have retribution
[Music]
and now it's time to join the revolution
as we take a quick look at one of our
titles that you may have seen at pax and
wasd the last aura crew
um
in the last aura crew you are in charge
of your story every decision you make
has an impact on the world around you so
how will you play will you join
revolution or will you bow to the queen
after all the spiritual healing flying
bullet space ai gun rogue it's time for
some good old-fashioned rts action so
let's take a look at one of our latest
rts's that launched in early access
crossfire legion
throughout the world
[Music]
global risk is an international military
giant
focus fire on targets
in the midst of all the chaos a new
institution has emerged called new
horizons
ready commander
but that's not all we are hosting a
series of community competitions in
cooperation with esl with the finals
being on the 28th of june so make sure
you tune in as we crown the first
crossfire legion champions
and of course iron harvest and our
favorite bear voyage can not be missed
last week we launched a big update and
here's a short trailer in case you
missed it
16.
if this battle is lost then there's
nothing to stop them
whatever it takes never before have we
waits for like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now a word from my friends over at
starbreeze
hello lucy and all the heisters out
there watching elizabeth here the
community manager for payday today we
invite you to learn more about our
upcoming campaign for payday 2 call
texas heat
[Music]
after the successful conclusion of the
story with the triads in san francisco
the pale gang is now traveling east and
south to texas in texas heat the paida
gang is contacted by notorious texan gun
runner gemma mcshay
she offers them a partnership to steal
some very valuable prototype weapons the
weapons are being held by rival gun
runner at his ranch in texas
it's a highly secure and fortified ranch
no cows lots of guns there might be more
than meets the eye here though as gem as
a person always thinks one step ahead
and always keeps an eye on where there's
more money to be made as the story
unfolds and the payday gang is drawn
deeper into texas expect to meet new
characters
and explore new locations
while texas heat is underway we still
take time to do other things like the
comically large spoon or the trading
card game whatever happened with that
anyway
today we want to take the opportunity
and say happy birthday to prime matter
from all of us in the payday crew
to celebrate our partnering crime and
inspired by the elements we put together
a gift for everyone in the patty
community including a new outfit and a
new song by gustavo access it all for
free by signing in on your starburst
account
[Music]
hi sters we hope you enjoyed what we had
to share with you today happy birthday
once again to prime matter we look
forward to continue working with you on
payday 3. don't forget to keep those
helmets flying
[Music]
[Music]
i am so incredibly excited to dive into
payday 2 with this awesome skin and fill
my heist and style so make sure you
follow us on twitter to find out when
we'll be tackling payday 2's new game
mode and of course we'll all be rocking
the skin who knows maybe it will bring
good luck
and that was it for our games but that's
of course not where we're ending the
show because with the magic of
television
when did you get back steve hello hi
when did you get back just now we're on
television don't freak out
uh
well there you have it guys
uh did you have fun i did yeah yeah yeah
it was so did i did i see a showdown at
some point don't don't mention it she's
everywhere she can hear you
okay
all right hey showdown
so now
now that's over and done with it's now
time for our q a segment so and let's
see how well if you've been paying
attention steve what was your favorite
game of the night
my favorite game hmm
probably the chant yeah yeah uh i'm
working on that title myself
um
yeah i'm looking forward to that because
i i like the the atmosphere in there
like um they say it's psychedelic horror
but like it's once you actually get into
the kind of real crux of the game
you you'll see what that's all about
just trust me
steve for me it would have to be system
shock but again i am a little bit biased
because i am you know working on that
title as a community an influencer
manager um but it is definitely one of
those titles that when you grew up with
that game and i've seen it you'll be so
happy to see how well they've adapted it
for modern times and of course we've got
the official theme behind it the
official voice actress and yeah you
heard shonen popping in kind of afraid
to say anything else then
then it's great system shot's great
fantastic best game fantastic
but it is now i'm truly excited about
that and i think original fans are
really going to love what the team has
done
awesome yeah i'm really looking forward
to it
uh and now we're going to look at
exactly yours some of your questions so
with the power of more magic
should we have a look so
i think it's a question for you steve is
the chant of psychological terror or
splatter hack and slash so like i kind
of just touched on
the chant is a cosmic horror kind of
psychedelic horror title that's going to
really challenge your
kind of body mind and spirit
body mind and your spirit
um it's a yeah it's very interesting
game um
definitely not a hack and slash don't be
expecting to be running around with guns
and with swords and stuff like that it's
it's definitely a little bit different
makes you think a little bit more we'll
just say that but keep an eye on the
social channels for the chart because
there will be a lot more news coming
very very soon on that one
should we try another one
sexy biscuit says
why i mean so awesome
our community is awesome and you guys
make us feel like we can put this out
here and and share our future games with
you guys thank you that we were just
born with it you know
fair enough well you're not wrong about
that but i was trying to give the
politically correct answer you know it's
you guys make us awesome but actually we
were worn out awesome
so i see another one from real gamer
here uh does the story of the last
horror crew adapt when you're playing
co-op um so the story doesn't adapt
necessarily when you are playing co-op
but um the gameplay will adapt so there
are certain levels where you can get
further ahead if you're playing with a
friend like quicker ahead should i say
of course the demo has already been on
steam and we've played a lot of the the
title on twitch and if you have seen us
uh you'll know that for example there's
like a lightning rod that you can use to
empower your co-player there's this big
spider that we call barry right barry
the spider by barry spider yeah and um
when you're playing with your friends
you can kind of unlock new tactics to
kill your enemies in a better way and of
course cope is very fun like any game is
more fun with friends i feel we're
totally going to be doing co-op streams
absolutely like it's the only thing
we're going to play
let's do another one cheese man my
favorite kind of man
regarding system shock remake how close
will the story follow the original or is
this a completely new reboot it will
follow the story um
it's it's honestly it's a very loyal
remake and that's really what the team
are focused on the most it's making sure
that this is the most loyal remake that
the fans are going to want to see so
don't worry um i've got full faith as an
old system shock fan in the game uh you
know i was too young to play it but i've
definitely watched streams of it i've
watched people other people play it so
and of course we very close with the
developers and we can tell you yeah
you're going to be happy with what
they're going to be putting out there
soon at some point nice
next question you can take this anymore
llama drama i love the name
uh how many times have you all
collectively died playing doorman which
boss was the hardest
okay
so i can take that one you're gonna take
that one at the last count
853
i think maybe 854 there might have been
a couple that we didn't catch
no um if any of you have actually caught
our streams uh for the chant uh our good
friend and well i say friend he's just a
colleague really
has been streaming the game a lot lately
and he is the pro amongst us um and he
dies like what twice in a stream and
sometimes we we play along with him
and we are literally yeah we're
literally dying every five minutes so
i'm glad you guys don't get to see what
but yeah a lot of times is the answer to
that question yes
over nine thousand i stopped counting
honestly and we've definitely rage
quitted a few times
pigeon catcher my favorite kind of
catcher uh when will we be able to play
gungrave so at the moment the release
window is full 2022
we don't have a set release date for you
at this time but do keep an eye on the
prime matter and gun grave gore social
media channels
for any more news on that um but yeah
fall 2022 just so keep your eyes peeled
and an appearance at gamescom as well
though i don't know in what regard
that's going to be may have to wait and
see have to wait and see
uh and the real gamer here loving the
username who's the artist behind good
and great gore and i think that's an
answer for you steve yeah sure
absolutely working closely on the game
yeah so gun grave gore uh is well gun
grave is a franchise that was developed
by a very famous mangaka called yasuhiro
naitao
he's most famous for the trigun series
um and yeah this was something that he
created there was an original game back
in 2002 i believe it was on the ps2
and yeah this is this is the kind of
next step in in that story so
he has been i think the um
he has been artistic um kind of
direction within this title so he's
heavily involved so fans of the series
uh can you know it's in good hands
let's see what other questions do we
have from mrs mittens
are there any more additions to the
rosters of cfl plant um we have released
a road map with all the additions
including unit updates maps and models
but you can head over to the steam page
where you will find out more information
about exactly what got updated and again
follow us on the socials to always stay
up to date with everything that's going
to happen but it will also be on the
steam page so make sure you head over
there
to find out more
is nurse your best friend uh the
question the answer to this is no uh
nurse is a colleague and he will always
just be a colleague no i'm joking
nurse is another one of our stream team
here part of our team and we love him
dearly so we do he is also the one who
is very much helping us with this entire
q and a section so big props to nurse
for putting his own question in there uh
and then there's another question about
the chant is the chant co-op the chant
is not co-op no it is a single player
narrative driven title so what you're
going to be uh looking at there is fully
immersing yourself and yourself alone
into that game the most important thing
with that title is just making sure that
the atmosphere is right and
having that title as co-op would not
suit the title i mean there are games
that it works and there are games where
it doesn't and the chant is one where
you need to experience it on your own
yeah having played a little bit of it i
i can absolutely agree with that yeah
yeah yeah we can still play it on stream
together though and like
playing at the same time and it's going
to be spoopy stuff
always
ooh another question from interesting
lies
like there's a question about gun grave
when will you show more
well
i can't answer that question for you
right now you'll just
there's more news coming in the very
very near future we've got a lot of
really interesting information to give
you guys about the game yeah but you're
i can't tell you when exactly you just
need to keep your eyes on the prize eyes
on the prize they say
somewhere
whenever we're ready to show i think
that that's a general answer like
obviously there's a lot of questions
right now with people saying when are we
gonna you know hear about the this and
this release date from this game and you
know especially like system shock payday
three and unfortunately we just can't
tell you because we don't have that
information for you and in this industry
everything is always ever changing
and um
so unfortunately we can't answer those
questions for you i don't know what
you're talking about
oh the next question can we take a
moment to talk about your shark shoes
i can't talk about that right i don't
know what you're talking about what
shark shoes what are you on about
i i don't see shark shoes
[Laughter]
next question
i think that was a that was beautifully
not i'm not i don't know anything about
any sharks
it's always shark week at primeta
anyone from morehouse horse studios
anyone feeling hungry actually you can
say that i'm actually really hungry
for some soap
we are actually quite hungry because you
know it's 7 p.m and uh i think the
nerves are definitely uh i mean they're
kind of gone now but they've definitely
burnt away all the food yeah we're
waiting for the takeaway to turn up yeah
yeah exactly we actually uh we had some
breakfast with waffles and ice cream and
whipped cream and then we had pizza for
dinner and i think for lunch and i think
that's definitely yeah we are big
advocates of healthy eating here
and waffles pizza
uh burgers
last night donut burgers is there is not
really the thing you should do before
getting on the screen in front of really
hot lights so that's not going yeah
um
this bunny says we saw a patch for
dorman on pc game and when will the
patch come to console players soon
unfortunately we don't have a date at
the moment for you but i can promise you
the dom and devs are really working hard
on all of the feedback that they have
received and they are working on
ensuring that there will be a patch soon
for console as well
yeah
sorry the dolman devs are listening to
absolutely everything that everyone says
we we even personally are in close
communication with them they are
absolutely fantastic guys so a big shout
out to massive work studio in in brazil
um
yeah they're just they're just the
nicest guys they're really really
amazing they really are working hard on
ensuring that those patches get out
there so don't worry um you'll be able
to
enjoy the game in this room soon as well
for sure until then you can turn into
our twitch and watch nerd play because
you know he's basically the pro is the
pros in that game yeah
i also see and sees here regarding the
last aura crew can i play the whole game
in co-op are there any limitations well
i mean as far as i'm aware the entire
game
is in co-op
and i believe if i'm not mistaken i'm
not working on this title so you have to
bear with me here but i am pretty sure
there is a little kind of introductiony
segment that you have to do on your own
but from then on everything can be done
in co-op um if there are little
limitations we can follow up on that
later for when there's more info to
share yeah and i know that in the twitch
primeter chat uh roxy or sexybiscuit is
there and she's the community manager so
maybe maybe she can quickly confirm but
i'm fairly certain uh you're gonna be
able to enjoy this game in his fullest
and co-op and i know we will be doing
that for sure yeah we're absolutely
gonna be doing that
uh the tactician the latest iron harvest
update is great will we see more
campaign maps uh that's a very good
question
um i think so
yes the answer is yes
keep an eye like the iron as i'm sure
you fans of iron harvest are very aware
the iron harvest community is very very
bustling and busy and any information
that will come along will be
available to see on discord and on
social media and everywhere
our night our fantastic colleague
that works on iron harvest is busy
wrestling away in the beginning yeah
yeah actually uh because obviously you
know we don't know everything
unfortunately i wish we did uh but i
just got information that yes there will
be uh more work done over the summer and
you can always make your own uh custom
games maybe showdown knows
maybe are you still here i think she's
gone you can't get the staff these days
right god
say wtb wanted my friends oh one will be
a friend yeah
will that new iron harvest update be
coming to console
when
i just told you i can't tell you that
we don't know
but however and not answering all right
so for questions like these that
unfortunately we can't answer
um please do head over to the iron
harvest social media channels where um
the iron harvest staff and community
will be able to help answer that
question for you um we can also answer
it later on on the parameter twitter
channels as well over streams over the
next coming uh weeks that we will be
having uh unfortunately we're not all
knowledgeable sorry
i try we try to be yeah it's not your
best friend yes we've already yes we've
already saved this yes yes
all right
um so are there any more questions from
chat okay that's that's the prime
question right like i mean we can check
chat ourselves as well
uh someone is asking where is toby from
uh war horse toby probably sat at home
watching the stream you better be do you
guys remember if you if you remember the
soap um episode he was sat on a sofa at
warhol studios he's still on that same
sofa he's been there since then um
watching himself
uh and i see a lot of questions about
games that we
just don't have any information on i'm
really sorry uh we'll encase it console
again not quite sure i don't think it
will um
so yeah i mean if there are any
questions about the games that we have
just shown and the games that we you
know have just talked about and we'd be
happy to answer um you know we've
actually played quite a few of the games
already so we do know a bit about the
gameplay about what the games look like
and as we said you know one of our most
exciting games is the chant uh which is
really going to show the type of horror
game that's going to have you on the
edge of your seat and i think
that's definitely something
that's going to be cool for the
parameter lineup it's really like a
narrative driven game
and it's going to have you thinking
about your
body
and your mind
and your spirit as well it's very
important that your spirit
involved to get involved yeah yeah i
it's
gets
think that's it so for anything that we
haven't covered or any questions that i
can't answer right now asking about
gimli and i think that's a really
important question uh gimli is actually
at my grandma's right now but next
stream next anniversary show that we
have we will get him here on stage
i think it's just i think it's just a
bit hot for him at the moment i think so
yeah weather is so hot you know it is
really warm in here so i think for this
stream
next time if we have a winter show
he'll be here with us like a little
little warm wood rug i would bring my
dog but he's a bit big
a little bit just a little bit so i
think for any uh questions that we
couldn't answer today uh or anything
that you want to know that's not been
covered today then just keep an eye on
the social media channels for these
titles
um
they are all available on twitter
and just keep an eye out and new news
will be coming in the very near future
yeah yeah uh and i think on that note
probably time to call it call it a day a
day and have some burgers oh god yes so
i think you know we want to mainly thank
of course everyone that has been here
with us today uh but also the prime
meter community
the prime matter staff and of course the
staff that we have here with us today
all the technicians behind the scenes
that have made it possible for us to be
here and mainly again the community the
players without you this wouldn't have
been possible and without you prime
matter wouldn't have been possible so we
want to thank you and for all the future
community members for those that have
now joined stream for the first time and
are like holy [ __ ] those guys
those guys are so cool um
yes we are we stream every week so make
sure you join our community because you
know we'd love to have you there tell
you what we're going to give away some
codes next week actually yeah yeah that
sounds like a great idea why not i've
already i've made that executive
decision right right i made that
executive decision
i am very very much down with this um so
over the next week you've heard it here
first can't say no now we're gonna have
some amazing fantastic games to give
away um and of course you get a chance
to play with us i mean she doesn't want
to play with us right
on behalf of everyone at prime matter
thank you for tuning in thanks everyone
for watching thanks for everyone who
hosted yeah and uh
we'll catch you on the flip side get you
on the flip side keep it prime keep it
prime boys and girls
come on it is a beautiful day
on
citadel station
station their number
like a countdown timer of the universe
you might not want to get close
covered in tattoos
feeling the fear i know you're feeling
i know what you're looking for is
revenge
it's up to us
to take humanity
forward their blood is on your hands
a pathetic creature of meat and bone
hello father
[Music]
[Music]
prime matter
[Music]
you